I can't wait to show you my toys there's
been some news lately that you guys are
maybe doing a little bit of reshooting
for Suicide Squad as well to make it a
little funnier something is that woo
that's well I guess the trailer was so
positively received with all the jokes
like my favorite part was like you're
just cracking but I assumed it was a
beer I don't know I was like this is the
most relatable moment to make it more
kind of bad I think there's plenty of
that you know I didn't I wouldn't say
we're going back to make it funny
there's some additional action stuff
that we've been doing which is pretty
dope yeah really we're just adding in
that sense yeah that was the that's what
the report was it was like oh the
trailer was so overseas laughing what I
keep being told I feel like that's a
common thing um well I was also reading
maybe I shouldn't believe us you know
that you're initially nervous to play
Captain Boomerang somewhat nervous not
so much like it's just that when you're
talking about the genesis of that
character was in like really camp like
60s comics and like you know you read
that old material and he's racist it's
like it's a very you know and this and
it's a real sort of it's a cliche like
old like all these stereotypes you
didn't want to be like a walking Outback
Steakhouse or just saying man I can't
say that like be proud of it as an
Australian you know what I mean but
thank God they gave it to an Aussie and
not you know trying to do a terrible
version of lxa